David Hogg do you remember David Hogg
he's one of the kids who he was at that
school in Florida where the shooting one
of the shootings took place and he used
that as an opportunity to become
somewhat famous and he immediately
jumped on TV and he turned this into a
small sort of celebrity industry for
himself and then he was accepted to
Harvard uh basically just on the basis
of going on TV a lot after a school
shooting and he's become a sort of
poster child for really simplistic
platitudinous liberal slogans so David
Hogg tweeted out something yesterday
that was really sad I'm not mentioning
this to dunk on David Hogg I'm on a
Mission of Mercy to try to help this
poor kid he tweets out quote
I'm never planning on having kids I
would much rather own a Porsche and have
a Portuguese water dog and golden doodle
long term it's cheaper better for the
environment and will never tell you that
it hates you or asks you to pay for
college
brutal now the immediate conservative
response to this I noticed a lot of
people in the comments section they said
great thanks bro please don't procreate
we don't need any more David Hogs I
don't think that's charitable and I
don't think that's the right thing to
say and I actually don't think it's even
the right way to think about politics
we are not going to get a more
conservative country by encouraging the
libs to to
become even more liberal
and self-centered and engaging and
disregarding marriage and disregarding
having children disregarding creating
Community structures that's actually not
going to work because yes maybe this guy
won't have kids but
he's going to
it's going to shape the way that the
political Community views itself and
over time it's going to make the country
more liberal even if he doesn't have
kids
we're actually not going to outbreed
them I don't think okay but furthermore
this is really this is sad
because it's not even that he's saying
I'm not going to have kids and I've got
some higher purpose he's not saying that
I don't think the kids are for everybody
I don't think the marriage is for
everybody
but you do need a higher purpose
you sh you really should not live for
brunch living for brunch is a dead end
it's going to make you completely
miserable and so many of my Millennial
and zoomer friends are doing it and they
are miserable as a result of it I can
see with my own two eyes
what's he say he doesn't say I don't
want to have kids because I want to
join the clergy you know I want to
become a missionary I want no he's
saying
I want to have a nice car
and some fun little want to have some
fun little dogs
and I I fear that if I have a child I
will love that child and that child will
let me down so I feel suffering at the
hands of people I love so I'm not going
to engage in love in the first place and
I fear losing my money because I don't
want to have to pay for college bro I
get it I get it
I know that it that I understand that
point of view and especially if you're
an atheist and you don't think there's
any real meaning to life and you think
we're all just kind of sacks of meat
stumbling around until we die and turn
to to worm food and take a dirt nap that
you could think that the purpose of life
is just to give yourself as much
pleasure
in a really shallow understanding of
pleasure as you can but that's not that
ain't it man C.S Lewis talks about this
he says
on on the subject of shallow pleasure
versus versus deeper pleasure he says
for a little child a little child cannot
imagine anything more wonderful and
enjoyable than chocolate
and if you mentioned sex to a child
which the libs I guess are doing these
days but if you were to mention sex to a
child the child wouldn't get it you say
actually sex is more more enjoyable and
pleasurable than chocolate
the child the child couldn't fathom that
because the child's frame of reference
is only that chocolate is the greatest
thing ever the child might actually
think huh
well I wonder if sex involves eating
chocolate bars because it's the only but
actually there are things that are
higher and although now modern Libs seem
to think that sexual pleasure with
random people is the highest possible
form of pleasure it's not
or much higher pleasures
like family which involves you actually
reducing the amount of sex that you can
have with random people you're actually
probably increasing the total amount of
sex you're having because you you have a
wife who likes you and will probably
feel some kind of nagging obligation to
indulge you every now and again so you
can
it will it will limit you in some ways
but it will open you up yes it's true I
love sleeping I don't get to sleep very
much now I love going out with my
friends and having cigars and drinks I
don't get to do that nearly as much as I
once did why not because I I have to
stay home and see my children
but it's not that I I get to stay home
and see my children The Joy while my
child is having a complete meltdown and
he's throwing gooey disgusting food all
over the place and there's a mess
everywhere and he's screaming and the
other baby starts crying and the the
anxiety that that induces and then I
just look over at my little kid and I
see his cute little chubby little cheeks
it's a little 19 month old baby cheeks
and he does a little kind of like a
little smile at daddy it is a joy that
it is so Sublime it's so
unfathomable when you're a kind of glib
lib just living for your own pleasure
that I know I know I can't actually
articulate how great it is but I promise
I promise you David Hogg I promise you
shallow glib Libs there are higher
things here there are higher things
beyond your own bassist desires and
appetites and and supposed interest but
actually your things that you were
pursuing today is your self-interest
really will not make you happy in the
long run
it's not making people happy now there's
a study that just came out of Harvard
surprising to everyone in the liberal
establishment not surprising at all to
normal people young people are miserable
they are totally freaking miserable okay
and Harvard can't make sense of it why
are young people so miserable quote
according to every dimension of
well-being that we looked at happiness
health meaning character relationships
Financial stability those who are 18 to
25 felt they were worse off
this according to Tyler Vander wheel who
conducted the study
they're worse off according to it would
it would make sense that young people
are
have lower reports of Happiness
according to certain metrics maybe than
certain Financial stability maybe
although I guess young people
depending on the family structure young
people might feel especially financially
stable because they're still relying on
their parents for certain things but but
yes certain criteria you could maybe
expect them to be a little less happy
maybe than others
but everything social relationships that
when you're young that's supposed to be
when you're most connected when you're
seeing so many people it's only when you
get old that you kind of stop making
time to see your friends and you become
more isolated your friends die why are
young people miserable on every
metric
we've been told that all of the
progressive advances in society are
supposed to make us all happier
but they have you could point to pretty
much anything that has changed in the
last 30 50 years
and you could say that is playing a role
in it technology isolating us from real
life we're told that when we get to live
in the metaverse that's so wonderful and
cool and hip and no it's not we we're
human beings we need to see one another
we need to touch one another
that's why during covid when people were
hugging through cellophane rappers that
was so inhuman
we need to and zooming everywhere we
need to see one another we're incarnate
creatures we have bodies
family life we're told it's super cool
now abandon your family don't get
married don't have kids you're gonna be
so happy because you don't get to go to
brunch in whatever City you're in this
weekend
doesn't make people happy and then of
course the core of it is religion as
religion has declined people have become
miserable and it is a direct one-to-one
ratio you might be an atheist you might
be an agnostic you I'm just you might
not even get it but I think you know I'm
right
think you know there's this weird
connection between the two right now
head on over to ring.com Knowles the
start of fall is always so busy
especially for me it's speech season now
I'm hitting the road all the time but I
can rest easy why because of ring alarm
now I know what you're thinking Ring the
video doorbell company they've got an
alarm they do ring alarm is an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself and ring did not
stop there they changed the home
security game with ring alarm Pro that
is why I love ring I strongly recommend
that you become a pro like me GoPro with
ring alarm Pro ring alarm Pro is a whole
home security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe to ring protect Pro ring alarm
Pro combines a security system with a
fast Euro Wi-Fi 6 router for home
security and network security in one
device your physical home your digital
home you get it all
if anything happens professional
monitoring calls and can request
emergency services
this fall whether you are in your home
whether you're at the office whether
you're across the country make sure that
you are protected okay head on over to
ring get ring alarm Pro ring.com Knowles
that is ring.com Knowles I'm so glad you
like that clip now here's what you got
to do you've got to ring that Bell ding
dong ring it click it like it zap it Bop
It
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]